this video is brought to you by
skillshare
[Music]
what's up guys jared here to talk about
the movie that made the oscars cool
again that's right parasite a film so
mind-blowingly awesome it would leave
even the most verbose cinema enthusiast
completely speechless at this point
repeating praise for parasite and its
director bong joon ho is kind of like
vaping everyone's doing it and it's kind
of a waste of breath so we'll save any
further gushing for our diary parasite
was celebrated all over the world for
its nuanced take on wealth inequality
but bong joon ho's scathing critique of
modern society goes way beyond its
riveting plot points which is why today
we won't be delving into the narrative
or the meaning of the title or the
meaning of that scholar's rock though if
you want to hear more on that be sure to
check out the parasite episode of our
movie podcast show me the meaning
instead we're going to focus on some of
the visual details of the film of which
even the smallest elements augment and
enhance parasite's overarching critique
fittingly for a film about money all of
the material things we see on screen
from the pizza boxes to the windows
serve an important symbolic purpose
let's find out how in this wisecrack
edition on parasite and of course
spoilers ahead for an oscar-winning best
picture that we actually shockingly
agree with but before we get into it i
want to give a shout out to skillshare
after work i love to sit down and watch
a movie or play some video games but
every once in a while i get into this
creative groove where i just want to put
some work into developing a new project
enter skillshare an online learning
community with hundreds of classes on
business design productivity freelancing
and so much more in the past i've
recommended classes like susan orlean's
creative non-fiction write truth with
style which definitely helps people who
want to organize their writing but i've
recently been watching classes that
focus a bit more on physical production
in iphone filmmaking i learned about
iphone videography and all the
surprising advantages of using your
mobile device to tell a compelling story
for just 10 a month you can have access
to classes like this that will get your
creative juices flowing it's great if
you want to bolster up your knowledge
about your own field or learn something
completely new the first 500 wisecrack
fans to click the link in the
description will get a two month premium
membership for free so start learning
and join skillshare today and now back
to the show alright guys let's do a
quick recap parasite centers around the
cunning destitute kim family who dream
of escaping their lousy semi-basement
apartment they scam their way into the
lives of the very wealthy park family
using increasingly devious methods to
find work as their tutor art therapist
driver and housekeeper things are
looking up until they discover they're
not the only family leeching off the
parks the former housekeeper's husband
has been camping out in the house's
hidden bunker for years to hide from
debt collectors tensions between the two
working class families mount and
everything crescendo's at a very bloody
birthday party that leaves several dead
after stabbing mr park mr kim retreats
into the bunker to hide for the
foreseeable future meanwhile the kim's
son fantasizes about earning enough
money to buy the house and free his dad
that's the bleak bleak end appropriately
enough for a story revolving around a
hidden basement bunker architecture
really matters in the film the grungy
reality of the kim's semi-basement
apartment contrasts with the opulence of
the park's glamorous home to effectively
create two different worlds a lot of
attention has been paid to the
architecture of the houses in part
because the entire movie was filmed on
sets built specifically to fit bong's
vision upon close inspection you'll find
that every choice made in creating these
sets was carefully calculated the kim's
home is based on real semi-basement
apartments that were built across seoul
during the cold war to provide shelter
in case of a north korean attack though
renting out semi-basements was banned
for years due to these squalid living
conditions south korea's economic boom
led to such overcrowding that the
government relented we see the paltry
living conditions of the kims they
reside in a dirty concrete building
surrounded by stink bugs
as if to literalize the fact that they
are at the bottom rung of the economic
ladder they live below ground and must
walk down a set of stairs to get to
their front door at the same time
everything in the house suggests a
solidarity among these family members
their socks hang from the same hanger
and underwear covers the walls of the
bathroom in contrast the park's house
feels definitively not specific to south
korea rather it mimics the modernist
style that was originated by western
architects like richard nutra louis khan
and frank lloyd wright the ultimate
realization of the modern aesthetic was
the glass house and the park's home is
nearly just that fishbowl-like and how
much it can reveal it also features
other modernist touch points like a flat
rooftop an open floor plan and an
overall minimalist aesthetic according
to our curator donald albrecht modernist
architecture as seen in cinema has
developed a cluster of connotations of
affluence glamour and escape houses that
embody that aesthetic abound in major
cities all over the world from tokyo to
oslo in a form that critic kate wagner
has dubbed the mcmodern because of their
tendency to each contain the exact same
hodgepodge of modernist design
aesthetics that is they all seem to be
inspired by the kimye school of
architecture sociologist sun ki chai
agrees that the home indicates a sort of
nouveau riche aesthetic and establishes
the parks as not just the one percent
but the highest level of the one percent
the parks as among a select elite who
have managed to succeed in a ruthless
capitalist world also fittingly must
walk up multiple staircases to access
their home it's also worth noting that
modernist architecture has some pretty
deep cinematic routes most playfully
identified by designer and writer
benjamin critten in his books evil
people in modernist homes in popular
films and sad people in modernist homes
and popular films as crittenden's titles
indicate films will frequently depict
modernist homes as the lair of a villain
like in blade runner or the big lebowski
or even the incredibles 2 or as a
metaphor for the emotionally empty lives
of its residents as in a single man or
the ice storm this makes it a fitting
home for the park family who though not
exactly the antagonists nonetheless
emerge as the central subject of bong's
class critique their part villain and
their obliviousness to the suffering of
those less fortunate and their part
tragic figures with the mother
apparently suffering from substance
abuse and the young sun harboring some
trauma all in all the perfect residence
for this modernist mecca we could spend
forever talking about the architectural
choices in this film take for example
each house's main window the kim's is
short with a severe frame facing a fence
that gives it a cage-like feel part of
our view out of the window is obscured
by a hanging rack of plain socks as if
to accentuate the fact that in such a
cramped space every bit of wall or
ceiling must serve multiple purposes
what we do see is a garbage filled
alleyway where drunken revelers often
relieve themselves the window is rarely
illuminated according to bong most
semi-basement apartments only get about
15 to 30 minutes of natural sunlight a
day the film opens with the kim sun
ki-wu slouching on an uncomfortable
looking couch soaking up a few of these
precious rays while struggling to steal
wi-fi access not the stuff capitalist
dreams are made of in contrast we have
the park's jaw-dropping floor-to-ceiling
window which was designed with a 2.35 to
1 aspect ratio like a movie theater
screen it looks out sans any obstruction
at an eden s garden that overflows with
sunlight the well thought out interior
design includes a plush couch to lounge
in while gazing out the window and
generally feeling pretty awesome about
your life that brings us to another
central difference between the two
houses the issue of space every surface
of the kim's home is cluttered with odds
and ends cleaning spray sits next to a
pair of shoes boxes are piled floor to
ceiling and the hallway doubles as a
closet what's more some proportions of
the home seem almost comically
misconceived like the elevated toilet
which production designer lee hajjun
designed to be as close to the ceiling
as possible as if to emphasize the
constant discomfort the kim's experience
the family is frequently crammed
together in close proximity as if to
emphasize both the uncomfortable
claustrophobia of their conditions and
their deep connectedness in contrast the
park's home seems to have never known
clutter the only things we see are
strategically intended for display from
the wine fridge to the family glamour
shot to the sprawling glass cases of
pricey dishware the small touches of
disorder that crop up from time to time
like the young park boys toy arrows are
quickly confiscated from view by a keen
eyed housekeeper fittingly and contra
the kim's the parks are rarely seen in
the same room together almost as if the
excess of space has compartmentalized
each member and unlike the basic layout
of the kim's apartment the sprawling
design of the park home is rife with
hiding spots that make for easy
eavesdropping and glass walls that make
for well eye dropping this suggests that
though their house might be well
protected from the outside world with
its fancy video security system once a
crafty family like the kims make it
inside the parks are left relatively
defenseless against their manipulations
just as architecture helps tell bong's
story of wealth and equality so too do
the choices he makes about representing
food food is an issue indistinguishable
from class particularly in a country
that has experienced severe food price
inflation in recent years on a basic
level food serves as an important
indicator of wealth and parasite at the
beginning of the film we see the kim's
folding pizza boxes for pizza generation
doing low paid labor for a restaurant
that seems to encompass the
globalization that's made life in south
korea so competitive it seems that they
can't even afford to eat the pizza
indeed the screenplay notes the sad
empty fridge and korean food journalist
joe mcpherson points out that we see the
family early on subsisting on moldy
white bread cheap chips and f light
which according to mcpherson is the
cheapest malt beverage on the market
once the kim start working for the parks
they gain some disposable income and
their rise in classes illustrated by the
gradual improvement of their diets first
we see them eating at a driver's
cafeteria which chai notes are known for
cheap filling buffets that working class
chauffeurs could enjoy from there we see
them kicking back and dining out at
pizza generation being served by the
same employee who previously docked
their pay they've risen from lowly
workers to customers eventually they're
able to afford beef which they cook at
home in an la galbi style by this point
three of the family members have
progressed to sapporo beer an expensive
import from japan their food journey
culminates when the parks go on vacation
and the kims get to play pretend in
their fancy house they enjoy bottled
water from the fridge as well as a wide
array of classy foods like shellfish
oysters and an even wider array of
alcohol most amusingly ki jung
accidentally noshes on the park's dog
treats confusing them for human food
underscoring the fact that the park's
pets likely eat better than the kims do
the parks gnash on colorful plates of
intricately arranged fruit a
particularly expensive commodity in
south korea in contrast the kims pile
their plates with rice and vegetables at
the buffet for the parks food is a
matter of enjoyment for the kims it's a
matter of survival while the kims
carefully ration every piece of bread in
their pantry the park boy can tear into
leftover birthday cake without a second
thought at other points food embodies
the dichotomy between classes that fuels
the film's drama most notably this
happens when mrs park instructs mrs kim
to cook ramadan a name made up by the
film's english translator to describe a
korean dish that mixes elements of ramen
and udon mrs park emphasizes that the
ramadan should be topped with expensive
sirloin steak and confirms that it's
been cooked through before she indulges
in an interview bong noted that this
choice was very intentional this dish is
typically seen as a meal for poorer
folks but it happens to be the park boys
favorite dish bong explains that while
children might not understand the class
connotations of food the rich wife would
still be uncomfortable feeding him cheap
noodles for dinner so she added the
ritzier sirloin as a topping
appropriately this means that the pricey
sirloin steak sits on a bed of common
noodles as if literalizing the message
of the film like steak over a bowl of
noodles the film shows multiple images
of wealthy folks metaphorically and
literally on top of poor folks but
there's another layer to the interplay
of food and class namely because food
has played a central and devastating
role in the kim family's economic
history at one point the kims reference
a chicken shop they owned that went bust
as well as an unsuccessful taiwanese
cake shop
as journalist s nathan park notes the
number of fried chicken joints in south
korea tripled between 2003 and 2013 and
then more than doubled again from 2013
to
part of this was a response to the 1997
asian financial crisis which left many
middle class koreans without work and
forced them to become self-employed low
interest rates made it easy to take out
alone and thousands took the gamble on
opening a mom and pop fried chicken shop
of which many like the kims would
inevitably fail then the family opened a
taiwanese cake shop attempting to
capitalize on a fad that swept korea in
2016. this turned out to be an even more
precarious business and when the bubble
burst thousands of shop owners like the
kims were left bankrupt or like the
housekeeper and her husband were left
deeply in debt in this way the
references to the family's history
according to park evoke a whole world of
middle class failure reflecting economic
hopes and tragedies that still resonate
throughout the country it shows us that
the kims weren't always living in
poverty they were once middle-class
business owners it was their inability
to turn food into a livelihood that
ultimately crippled them there's one
other aspect of the production design
that feels too important not to name
specifically the array of native
american themed toys that the park sun
constantly plays with ranging from a
teepee to a headdress to a bow and arrow
here we see the boy enjoying american
commodities the mother even brags that
the teepee comes from america which chai
says probably makes her feel
cosmopolitan
chai notes that in south korea there's
still a sense that certain things from
america are high class particularly
education aptly mrs park perks up
immediately upon hearing that a
potential tutor has been educated at
illinois state university
at the same time it's interesting that
the boy is imitating native american
culture rather than playing say american
cops and robbers here we think bong is
being a bit sly the park boy is
unknowingly taking on the fashions and
cultural objects of a historically
brutally mistreated demographic of
americans for his own amusement this
only bolsters our sense that the parks
exist in a blissful bubble of privilege
as bong puts it the actual history of
native americans is very complicated but
the mother and the boy don't care about
the complexity at all it's just a
decoration for them at one point the boy
sleeps outside in his teepee in the rain
as if role playing a less fortunate life
than the one he leads brilliantly and
uncomfortably at the exact same moment
the parks lie on the couch sexually role
playing a scenario in which mrs park is
selling sex for drugs the two
simultaneous narratives evoke the
family's obliviousness to and disregard
for the realities of living in poverty
safe and secure in their wealth
pretending to be poor turns a grim
brutal way of life into a fun daring
game parasite creates a modern
capitalist fable that warns of the
immorality and dark implications of
income inequality and within the film
every set prop or slice of pizza
contributes a little bit to that message
but what do you guys think is bong joon
ho a freaking genius is parasite a fun
family thriller or a subtle invitation
to set fire to the system let us know in
the comments thanks again to our
incredible patrons for supporting our
podcasts and the channel go ahead and
click that subscribe button and as
always thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
you